so next game looking for the
lost
number opponent comes from India has
gkg3
well so double in
shatum yes that's of course
a
quiet solid setup for
black yes you always don't know whether
you should react to it in some way
on
A5 well I do  do A4 and then if
black now moves D5 then it's a
bit uncomfortable here with the
structure W the knight is wrong aha we
move B5
actually
t yes he can
do it yes black can
play quite a lot purely purely from the selection point of view
the white one too  It's not that
super powerful, somehow it's
of course surprising. I thought now
with the rook A5 should actually
be weak.
Well, knight B6 can
play tur 5 knight D5 well,
but I wanted to go
back anyway, so now the question is how he
actually
holds A5 now  everything on the
spot od he gets it
preferred I don't see it at the moment
BA knight rook bishop rook does he have
some trick sometimes works yes
things like that here rook B2 I
don't think
so passed pawns should run or what was
it like A6 now W I even up to  well A7
come
no can he pick it up I do
n't
like
so okay a lot of people try
to get to it a few more times
but okay so now you can't
do anything directly but you can of course
now gain more space in the center,
yes  Don't put everything on
the down pawn now
so the bishop is pretty stupid in the
position here that's why we don't want to let it be
exchanged directly for
knight so we can
go back like this and knight D3 so now
you're actually good in the center
yes yes maybe try that  Somehow I can
rework it so that he
can take it,
but I don't really think so.
He has to attack the thing with a minor piece
and that
somehow does
n't work, or move the knight rook
C7, that takes
forever, so
F4,
yes, now we can do that too  still move E5,
what happens if I take it now and
knight E4 looks dangerous
or t dangerous is an understatement,
D6 is hanging and knight F6 was
threatening. Knight C5 was also
threatening, well, okay, but the chess should
actually be good,
okay  Did he give up by breaking
the connection,
so to speak? Yes, the
pawn was practically gone. It's strange, of course,
that he took it here when
Black now plays B4 or somehow
stops. I don't know Bishop A6
or something like that. I don't think there's
much going on, maybe one  a bit of an
advantage for white but nothing great
like that